the Joe Rogan experience let's talk
about Sean Oh Miley I'm just I just want
to break these even somebody like him
listen to his interviews and you you
study these guys you see work with their
mindset is and where their holes are
gonna be it's like they had asked him
and who do you want to ask Sean among
who do you want to fight next and he's
like you know I just want to fight you
know I just want to fight the best
strikers like he never mentioned about
I'll take anybody out I'll take anybody
in the top ten or 15 or whatever because
in my opinion hasn't really beats
somebody that's like okay man you're the
real deal even though he did be wildin
and he was a contender but it's it's
been a long time and then he's a young
kid that's learning the sport while
we're watching him on the UFC that's
what's crazy about him I mean you won't
you go back to Dana White's contender
show and he was looser wilder you know
fun to watch but not nearly as sharp
okay now he's on a completely different
level knocking out Weinland like that
faking the uppercut and then just
following over the top of the straight
right hand and catching him slipping I
mean that was that was fantastic but
that's that's the point that I'm trying
to get to is it's it's it's a striking
game for him right now like there is a
whole nother aspect and that's called
wrestling and jiu-jitsu Neph one I've
heard he's he has developed pretty good
jiu-jitsu but there's that other art
that I want to see when you're really
good tests and you're taking it to deep
waters then I'll see you real colors
then I'll be like okay man you are ready
to take on anybody in the tough I'm
gonna give you a good example that Yuri
Rodriguez when he fought Frankie Edgar
that was a good example that this
Frankie Edgar was just that wrestling
was too strong that ground pound was too
strong he couldn't keep him off him he
just couldn't do anything about it and
that was a great example that because
yeah year was this super flash kicker I
mean yeah here to me has some of the
best kicks I've ever seen inside the
Octagon
Wow flashy [ __ ] man when he threw that
he threw against BJ hit him with a 360
roundhouse kick to the face that's no
[ __ ] to pull off in a fight
yeah 360 roundhouse kicked him in the
face the ire was a beast and everybody
was like really thinking you know
he's on short path to the title but the
big hole was that wrestling that was it
was exposed by how elite Frankie is and
how he'll when Asti Frankie's
ground-and-pound is it was a major
beat-down you know and that's one of
those fights where you watch a guy and
you go this guy it's it's all about
styles because it's all about you know
whether he'll give you four if he found
someone that played his game like oh
[ __ ] he's good at that game
but what Frankie did is just completely
impose his game just drag him down and
beat him up and then we don't know what
would happen with O'Malley when it comes
to that but I know who he is as a person
and he's working he's working on
everything that kid is he's focused as
[ __ ] he keeps getting better and better
and better like in a trippy way like
when you saw him come back after two
years off you know two years dealing
with a bunch of bull should I forget
what he was suspended for I don't
remember what it was was it was it was
it marijuana that doesn't make sense
tainted supplements hasn't been a
protein or something yeah anyway I'm
interested yeah it's and it's making a
banner with division with guys like that
it's making an exciting
[Applause]